the era of television the greatest
advance in television in the 60s and 70s
TV had become such an icon that that
artist couldn't resist just fully with
it it was all pretty much new and it was
really taking sort of your standard TV
sets and just making it really crazy but
the inherent vice of televisions is it
is a consumer electronic unlike painting
that sculptures these electronic pieces
they could just go any time that was
always a big threat to this in a museum
you have these pieces that if it breaks
down what do you do the first person we
call is Cindy Willy
Louise always been the first person we
go to it's because of my father they're
able to be maintained they're able to be
shown they're able to be put out in the
world within the conservation field this
is critically necessary you can see just
the enthusiasm he has for this
technology
[Music]
my name is Chetan Louie I'm the
electrical engineer and technician I was
born in Chongqing during World War two
and after the war we moved to Shanghai
and then from there we went to Hong Kong
and Taiwan
ever since I kid I was a tinkerer I like
to take things apart take watch a cloth
take everything apart
I always interesting how things were my
first time learning TV was very
difficult they're talking about scanning
Sawtooth sign way all drive you crazy
and also the Taiwan there's no TV bucket
only watching snow so I never see TV
working until I come to America the
easiest job for me to do the TV repair
shop are going there and right away
there Jaime I repair deviate and I'll
make it love it I started my own
business in 1969 my pleasure face it is
like a hub for video customer all the
orders to be here I show all the new
equipment when people started using
video as sort of this experimental media
so everybody was sort of wanting to know
how it worked what you could do with it
people like Andy Warhol down learning
the boy come upon me that's how I meet a
Woody Allen or Shirley Clark
princess couple of come visit my shop
every weekend my talent is also take the
equipment custom-fit to what they like
it's a lot of fun to work with
[Music]
today my most award is conservation form
using any art in value like China's
become to me they want to maintain
original so my guys to refurbish them
try to maintain the same look most of
time the TV is paper now or the
electronic component failure I also know
where to get parts I I know if just tube
doesn't work I know for to substitute
they calling me because my reputation
with the original artists any major
institution that has video are probably
my father has touched in some way I
helped MoMA the Whitney Guggenheim the
mad I want to keep all the artists
I'll work alive that's my job I think
that's my my duty and they keep me alive
as long I could do that
it's really a lot of fun
you